we have lost objective done
assault over the years you've had all
manners of explosives to launch it
enemies and that hasn't changed much in
the battlefield 1 alpha assault class is
the only class that can take two types
of grenades out on the field an
anti-tank grenade and players choice
personally I've come to love the gas
grenade through this alpha the other
state will be assault class is the
anti-tank launcher this previously was
the engineers RPG the poor engineer has
been dissolved in his gear spread across
other classes and vehicles your first
reaction when using assault might be to
go after vehicles directly at range
because you're the only class that can
do that but you need to be more of a
team player when matches start assault
is the only class that can destroy walls
which means you should start every
battle by preparing the field for your
teammates blow open the tops of
windmills facing objectives to give your
Scout players sight lines open up
addicts for support to fire out of and
remove cover for the opposing team
now you're getting it when it comes to
the guns in the Alpha the assault has
the model 10 shotgun the MP 18 SMG and
the m1918 SMG I found there's no
contender to the m1918 which fires a
whopping nine hundred rounds a minute
and cannot be beat at close range except
for by well-placed shotgun rounds from a
fellow assault player or medic we have
taken objective Freddie I found no
reason to use the other weapons
especially since after throwing a gas
grenade into a building all players are
forced to don their gas masks and fire
from the hip that puts the assault class
at a distinct advantage when it comes to
a battle buddy grab a support player to
keep you stocked with rockets depending
on the type of tank you may need several
rockets and that's assuming it doesn't
shoot back unlike the RPG you can't
stand and fire the launcher so you'll
need to find places to set it down a
support player with a scope can even act
as a spotter for you to take those long
range shots other than that getting good
with the bayonet charge is a very useful
skill do charge it enemy players from
behind do not charge it enemy players
from the front do use the charge to
cross exposed up and ground or to get
away quickly do not end your charge in
the middle of expose ground and that's
about it for assault just remember if
the enemy team is hiding in the Attic
your assault blow up the darn thing
if you'd like more battlefield 1 videos
hit that subscribe button on YouTube and
give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'll see you out on the
battlefield
you